the vocal minority of students who
actually want censorship who actually
want to be protected from ideas they
don't like there was always they were
always existed but in the last five
years they have gained institutional
power on these campuses where
administrators now have to listen to
what they say
I remember at a reason that weekend I
think it was about seven eight years ago
I was Greg lukianov from the foundation
of individual rights and education
fires based here in Philly we got he
fire people here so I was just talking
to Greg privately and he was telling me
the various horror stories from campus
and my remarks to him was like it's
weird and this is shows how long seven
or eight years ago can feel because at
that time the term like politically
correct had died right people weren't
talking about it and he's like no it's
happening just as much as it ever did
but for some reason everybody talked
about it in 1992 and 1993 I guess what
happened is that Bill Maher started
politically incorrect as a show and so
everyone you know declared victory and
went home also the organ to the
journalistic outlets like salon comm and
it's early
presentation was directly supposed to be
a politically incorrect place that David
Horowitz as a columnist in Camille
Paglia and these kind of people who who
traversed normal ideologies and so
people thought it went away and it
didn't it just the the attention span
wandered and went away well needless to
say we have now rediscovered on a
national scale how much political
correctness on campuses and anti-free
speech measures on campus has returned
and with a vengeance and part of the
reason why we know this is sitting next
to me Robby's suave here who's been with
reason for two three years now Robbie
has been writing about this stuff for us
and it's been a nap salute revelation
both his work which has been honored by
a lot of people you want to Southern
California journalism prize for his work
last year being the essentially the
second journalistic skeptic of the
University of Virginia rape hoax story
that Rolling Stone perpetrated on the
world but he's been writing about campus
free speech campus sexual assault and
there is no shortage of material about
the Boche style hellscape of
microaggressions and safe spaces and all
this nonsense that have come up and you
know people like Nick and myself might
pat ourselves on the back for all the
great work that we do Robby is running
rings around us traffic-wise
on online his reporting on this has been
really instrumental he was named Forbes
one of 30 under 30 something or others
there I don't really know yeah no he
said he's done really great work and so
what I want to get out of him a little
bit here is whether we are actually
seeing a huge spike because it certainly
feels like it sitting as an old person
on the outside of college campuses and
this type of a nonsensical and nefarious
behavior before we get him at since this
might be some of your first time meeting
our italian-american friend over here
and we'll have a little ask a millennial
session later with him but just to give
a quick sense of how a nice kid from
Michigan ended up becoming a libertarian
sure so I I grew up in a what you would
describe as a Republican household
although my parents were I think always
libertarians and they certainly describe
themselves that way now but so when I
went to college at the University of
Michigan I was describing myself kind of
as like a hard right conservative to
sort of annoy other people on campus and
I quickly became annoyed with the campus
publication the mainstream student
newspaper the Michigan daily just a
constant string of very far left
editorials and columns and nothing but
that so I wrote a I wrote a letter to
the editor or something and then they
actually hired me to be like a
conservative columnist for them and I
wrote something about I think it was
about film subsidies in Michigan the
crony capitalism of the film industry
and the Mackinac Center for Public
Policy saw the column they reached out
to me they in
me to attend a seminar and then they
kind of exposed me to the broader of
libertarian movement I found out from
them about reason the students for
liberty were starting up around that
time and I became involved with them and
then sort of the rest of the philosophy
of libertarianism came to me at that
time and then I actually kept working
for that publication I became a editor
of the opinion page for the far left
socialist
campus paper so so that was a fun
experience writing writing editorials I
just emphatically didn't agree with and
I had to write them in the institutional
voice of the Michigan daily but that's
that was a worthwhile experience and I
hope has informed my or left me able to
engage what people on the Left say that
I maybe don't agree with but I
understand where they're coming from and
and that was a good paper that day now
it's now it's a bastion of political
correctness has changed in the last five
so you graduated when like 2010 2010
have things on campus gone and got
materially worth did this all really get
re started since then yes why so so Greg
is right that things didn't Gregg lucky
enough that things didn't didn't go away
there was always administrators wanting
to censor students step on their toes
restrict their political activity almost
not from an ideological standpoint but
from a reputational from a harm to the
from to the PR concerns of the
university that's what there always were
- this looks bad to the Alumni
Association if these kids are you know I
don't know passes having an affirmative
action bake sale or distributing condoms
or doing any right or left anything that
could embarrass the institution so
they're always in administrators doing
that but what has changed in the last
five years is that the vocal minority of
students who actually want censorship
who actually want to be protected from
ideas they don't like there was always
they were always existed but in the last
five years they have gained
institutional power on these campuses
where administrators now have to listen
to what they say and
afraid to not take their demand
seriously and there's a clear reason why
this has happened is the federal
government the Education Department
began five years ago to the day last
month instructing colleges to complete
that they had to comply with this little
known statute called title nine which
prohibit which actually just prohibits
gender discrimination there's nothing
wrong with it it's one sentence long but
the Education Department has taken it to
mean that harassment the universities
have an obligation to prohibit or
prohibit harassment and harassment is so
broad so subjective anything that
offends you could be harassment in the
normal legal context it must be severe
it must be pervasive it must offend a
reasonable person on campus it's an
entirely subjective your professor could
be harassing you if they're instructing
you on maybe a Shakespearean text that
has violence or sexual assault in in it
if you're a you have some experience of
that so that so the university
professors are now eschewing talking
about those subjects because they don't
want to be investigated by the
university's title 9 Bureau can you
things are happening just to interject
what are some of the real-world examples
of title 9 just kind of bizarre
inquisitions that result from the best
and most famous example is the the
Inquisition against professor Laura
Kipnis at Northwestern University she
had written an op-ed for The Chronicle
of Higher Education about how title 9 is
chilling speech and and limiting
professors and students abilities to
form relationships and learn from each
other and how it was having a pernicious
effect on the climate on campus
this was her op-ed her students who
didn't like the op-ed filed a title 9
complaint against her arguing that she
was retaliating against them by talking
about the title 9 environment so she was
I mean you know speaking of retaliation
they they so then the university is is
required to take this complaint
seriously
just say this is farcical we're ignoring
this they don't want to look
insufficiently committed to policing
harassment on campus so they they put
her through a process where she doesn't
have a lawyer she has a support person
actually the support person she had was
so vocal about how this was an injustice
that people filed title nine complaints
against him as well and he was pulled
from the process and had his own his own
thing so she has to meet with the
university's lawyers actually the
university hired a team of lawyers they
flew them in it this just you know me
adjudicating this one thing cost the
university like hundreds of thousands of
dollars and you and we wonder why
tuition is going through the roof
eventually you know months later it all
it all went away and she didn't get
fired or anything but but the message
you would take away from this experience
would certainly be I'm better off not
criticizing title nine I don't want to
especially if you're not tenured if
you're an adjunct a lot of professors
are really actually precarious positions
they don't want to say the wrong thing
so they can't even denounce this
environment it's a real problem the the
American Association of University
Professors actually and you know this is
a left-of-center group I would describe
them as recently came out with a report
about the abuse of title nine and how
this is just having a bunch of other
professors have have gone through this
and they're really worried about it talk
a little bit about how these title nine
changes also affected due process and
adjudication of sexual assault on campus
sure it's it's kind of funny because
there are different issues but what's
wrong on campus with the free expression
and with due process they're coming from
the same they had the same event at
their center title nine which is why I
write about both of them in addition to
kind of chilling speech out of
harassment concerns the Education
Department has also interpreted title
nine to mean that I universities must do
more to police sexual violence sexual
misconduct on campuses and they said
they see in this guidance that came out
five years ago they said that if someone
if you if you know of an instance of
sexual abuse you have to end
to get it according to all these
ridiculous methods that would violate
the most basic standards of due process
if it were a criminal proceeding that
you have to use the preponderance of the
evidence standard meaning that if the
administrators who have no legal
training who or who don't understand the
rules of evidence who don't permit
cross-examination who sometimes don't
even make the person the accused person
aware of the charges against them
they're deciding this on a preponderance
of the evidence standard which means
just 51% sure rather than a stronger
evidence standard which is what you
would have in a in a normal criminal
case and and these are in some of these
situations it's not even a actual
dispute between students the most recent
one I covered at Colorado State it was
an athlete and a trainer both students
consensual relationship they're dating
the the the woman that the victim
describes it as a consensual
relationship her friend found out about
their relationship and reported it to
the University and she said when asked
she said no I'm fine I'm fine
I was not raped were her literal words
the university said well so says you
we're investigating that you know that's
up to us to decide the the they didn't
even use a panel they didn't even put it
to a group of people and this is
increasingly popular the single
investigator model versus a hearing
model where the college charges one
bureaucrat with deciding with
investigating and then deciding this
whether the allegations have merit they
you know he's trying to say well you
should interview her you should
interview all these people that know was
a consensual relationship the
administrator said I am I am the
interviewer I will do the interrogating
I get to pick who I talk to so he was
found guilty he was suspended for two
years for sexually assaulting someone
who said that he had not sexually
assaulted her said that repeatedly and
this is this is the sec this was the
second case in two weeks that I covered
where there was not actually a dispute
between the two people and its title
nine it the colleges are afraid of
looking insufficiently committed to the
admittedly noble cause of reducing
sexual assault on cam what is the what
is this
stick with which title nine beats you
into submission if you do not comply
with their directors the the Education
Department has said these universities
public and private will will lose
whatever funding they're getting from
the government if they are violating
title nine and and they you know it's
they always they put their language very
carefully they don't say they're saying
well this is this is our interpretation
of the guidance you're welcome to to
ignore it if you want who knows what
will happen then and when called when
called out on it by Congress they you
know they try to step away well we're
just interpreting this is just what we
think you know you can tell us something
different but the colleges are so
risk-averse there are powerful
institutions but they they're reliant so
reliant on the money the federal
government gives them it's it's an
between being sued down the line down
the road by students they've mistreated
they'd rather face that then then risk
the government cutting their funding
let's talk a little bit about the
culture that is sort of feeding this or
being caused by it or however you want
to portray it we have a situation now
where Chris Rock Jerry Seinfeld a couple
of other comedians how I've just openly
said we're not going on college campuses
anymore these people suck I'm time tired
of it I don't want you know they're not
ratina fey I think I said something
Jerry Seinfeld similar to that so is the
culture on campuses getting noticeably
worse and that cannot be title nine as
human beings why are they what's
happening I was reading so there was a
there was a story in the brown Daily
Herald the campus newspaper for brown a
couple weeks ago that got some headlines
these students these were student
activists liberal student activists on
the campus describing what their work
had done to their emotional state
these students saying they're suffering
panic attacks depression their grades
are dropping they are suicidal they
can't concentrate on anything because of
the inequality and injustice in the
university that they're working hard to
fight and then towards the end of the
article you got to so what was the
horrible injustice they were
to overcome it was that someone had
published an op-ed in the student
newspaper that they disagreed with it
was about how like it was a stupid
argument for like some there are some
benefits of colonialism or something was
that was the op-ed yeah which might be
wrong but certainly an idea worth
debating at a university that was you
know what they considered to be a almost
literal violence against them they were
listening to their language you would
think they had survived like a genocide
or a mass shooting or something that
they had survived this horribly
traumatic event so I'm trying to figure
it be that these students are are are
like this and I I think it's this new
power that the the most oppressed the
most marginalized the most victimized
person on campus has it's to their
advantage to portray them so I don't
think it's all sincere I think they
portray themselves that way because they
have power they get paid attention to by
the media now they get to social media
love and and there's a new and and by
the way this is starting the way before
these kids get to college the K through
12 system and the helicopter parenting
the things my colleague Leonor talks
about the the sort of vindictive
coddling of young people in schools they
think they're the the authority figures
treat them like they're in so much
danger all the time there's so much fear
of mass shootings in schools even though
schools are safer than they've ever been
before in human history of kids playing
by themselves in the park even though
parks are safer than ever before in
human history students who do anything
who act out a little bit are punished
who bring that you know bring their
fishing gear to school are expelled for
bringing deadly weapons the kid who
wrote a story about a dinosaur in which
he shot the dinosaur that kid was
expelled you know I see stories like
that every day so I think by the time
these kids get to college they've gotten
the message that that the world is scary
and people who who do things who test
the bounds of these rules are are are
have been weeded out of the system or
there's something wrong with that and I
think these a
significant portion of these kids are
getting to college and now and now
they're free now they can do whatever
they want but they actually what they
crave is this is the unnecessary
over-the-top protection that they've
grown accustomed to in their previous 16
years of their lives that they've gotten
from the institutions of Education and
and that they're turning to
administrators on campus and saying wait
a minute I've been told that you are my
my parental figure this was the the kids
at Yale this is with explicitly what
they said to the administrator who
wouldn't protect them from offensive
Halloween costumes they said your this
is your job this is your duty to make
sure we don't have to deal with this and
and I think that's you know enormous ly
troubling for those of us who want a
climate of free expression and maximum
experimentation and and and thinking
through and exposure to even to
controversial ideas is healthy but they
have been taught that it's very bad and
the authority figures it's their job to
protect them from it I went to school in
Santa Barbara where you know that we
were the college newspaper people
there's the student government people
and then maybe like the the you know
rock band trash people and we all we all
thought these was my people and we all
thought that the worlds that we wrote
about and cared about and dealt with
were the most important worlds out there
but in fact Santa Barbara's 18,000
people and about 17,000 are just
drinking pitchers of beer and playing
volleyball and they're in sororities and
fraternities have no idea what the rest
of us were talking about which is a way
of saying if you took a cross-section of
a college student and I'm not talking
about weirdos like these guys here but
like of if you took a bit out of the
median college student and just put it
in a microscope in a laboratory would
that person be a coddling safeSpace or
micro aggression person or they don't
even know what that's going on yeah I
don't think so at all I think I think
most students still want to come to go
to college they're interested in ideas
they like their classes they they are
not there they're not set in their views
they want to hear different ideas
they're there
what should be aspired to so it's I
don't think it's that most student I
don't I don't think it's at all students
are like this or even most students it's
just this vocal minority that has always
existed and now has gained institutional
power there is some evidence though I
you see studies of surveys of students
attitudes on free expression on
offensiveness on political correctness
these surveys it's hard to make a lot of
them because people give contradictory
answers when asked if they like free
speech it depends how you word it Thanks
everybody says they like free speech and
then you say well what if a cartoon that
offends religion let's say well not that
that's not free speech so it's hard
actually to see if students if the
majority of students on net if their
views are changing over time but I'm
looking at recent surveys I'm mildly
persuaded that this is moving the needle
for the majority of students a little
bit are are are now more worried about
offending and it's and it's different
people it used to be you know more and
more conservative students were offended
conservative religious students were
offended by things on campus and now
it's almost like they were maybe
Christian students were offended by by
things you know art making fun of
Christianity and now it's like the left
her students protecting Muslim students
from being offended is actually a big
thing on a lot of campuses so it I I
don't know that it's getting worse with
most students but certainly their the
their attitudes their their respect for
for the First Amendment it does seem to
be decreasing a little bit although I
still think it's more the bigger threat
is these empowered minority of very very
sensorial students is this an opera is
there a backlash forming our students
going what the hell is wrong with you
people and so therefore let's subscribe
to Reason magazine well I I hope so and
it's it's I think it's very important
for us in the room who are committed
libertarians to kind of take control of
this in Stuart because what I worry I
see a lot of disaffected students non
liberal students libertarian and
conservative students who who
hate this repression this environment of
censorship on campus but a non-trivial
number of these people are actually
turning to like Donald Trump type
figures because he complains about
political correctness and they're not
doing it out of a affinity for his views
but because actually just saying the
words Donald Trump on campus is like a
it's like an anti PC statement it's a
it's a no right it is just writing in
chalk on the ground Donald Trump 2016
has been considered an act of violence
I'm not no exaggeration at my campus the
University of Michigan there's a main
square on campus where people chalk
political messages all the time and and
someone wrote Trump 2016 and stop Islam
and and you know these are ideas that
are that you might not agree with or you
might not like but they're certainly not
on unreasonable to discuss them or
express them in a public square on a
college campus these students were so
offended they complained that there was
not a mert an emergency number they
could call at the police station to have
someone take care of this they did
eventually figure out that if you threw
water on the chalk it would take care of
itself but so I worry that but this was
a great so then the students have then
the kind of students who are who are the
anti PC students will have they have
they've invited sort of Trump pro Trump
figures and speakers to campus and so if
mileage innopolis is one of them and I
yeah I appreciate what he does to to to
make fun of the sensors and that has
value but I would rather it being done
from a principled libertarian standpoint
rather than just falling in with a
someone who is very PC in a different
way in a right-wing way you can't say
things about police officers and so on
and there's there's a conservative
political correctness too and I and we
want to be principled about it and not
kind of caught up in in the charlatan
that is from Robby as I mentioned at the
top of this has been instrumental in our
efforts over the last couple of years
which has been very conscious of
reaching more young people reaching a
younger audience and as
material in our annual or semiannual
board book points out I think 40 percent
of our online audience to reason.com two
out of five people I remember that much
for math are under 35 which in the
opinion journalism world is insane
seriously like if you the median viewer
of a cable news show is more or less 70
Age no no no it's not I'm not that's not
hyperbole median yeah the median at Fox
Business where I used to work it was
like 69 it was my dad is slightly older
than the median viewer on on Fox and for
newspapers and opinion sections opinion
magazines your average is just they're
all 60 plus or 50 plus and they're all
men and our are we have a reach and
recent TV is also very instrumental in
this in getting actually in front of
young people and Robbie's definitely
been part of that and the topic the
selection that kind of flows out of this
has been part of that too so he's
working people I want to get to uh ask
the Millennials a session here with with
a crowd here but where do you can you
give us before we we turn it over to
them give us a sense of where this is
heading the President of the United
States has told kids look you gotta
lighten up on college campuses he has
done it first is he self-aware that his
own administration is part of the
problem but then just kind of second is
is is the thing cresting is it gonna
move back what's what's gonna happen in
the next couple years yeah the president
has said multiple times the importance
of listening to different ideas I don't
think he's really aware of what the
Education Department has done and
unfortunately Hillary Clinton I think if
if president it would be about ten times
worse on these issues than the Obama
administration has been that said there
is certainly a in addition to a broader
awareness in the culture that the
political correctness broadly defined or
rather specifically defined as abject
censorship particularly on college
campus's has gone way too far and is a
problem some of these lawsuits that
students have filed actually now impune
the education department directly
they're actually naming the Education
Department as co-defendants in in their
lawsuits and also Congress seems
increasingly interested in reining in
title 9 particularly they've actually
accused it of violating the
Administrative Procedures Act which
sounds very boring and technical but but
they have a good case that that no one's
subjected this guidance to public
scrutiny and therefore it's it's
actually in violation of the law so I'm
hopeful that Congress or courts could in
the next couple of years
rein in some of this stuff it's cyclical
and and we could be at we could be
having things get better I think but I
would still say we're in for another
year or two at least of really
outrageous stuff on campus that no one
is doing a thing about other than us
bringing attention to it and kind of
making fun of them very good ladies and
gentlemen